歡迎收看泛科學新聞
大家2026新年快樂
這是泛科學新聞第40集
也是我們第二季的最後一集
謝謝每一位泛糰會員的支持
我們在年底終於壓線達到會員數的低標
因此泛科學新聞第三季
確定正式繼續連載啦
從下週起就進入第三季
同樣要拜託大家多多支持
希望在三月底之前
還沒加入會員的各位
能按下影片下方的那個加入鈕
當然希望能更早達標
這樣更安心啦
今年我們一樣準備了多檔重磅專題
全新的慢科學
以及許多希望能實現的新企劃
懇請各位乾爹乾媽現在就加入會員
本当にありがとうございます
會考會考的會考得很好
會考不會考的會考得不好
不管你會不會考
會考還是會考
會考會考就會考
很想祝大家真的都會考
不會的都不會考
但偏偏會考就是會考不會的
那怎麼辦
閱讀速度與擷取資訊的能力
才是拿高分的關鍵
泛科學和教育出版權威南一書局強強聯手
推出建構科普素養
培養閱讀實力的科學生
想要會考會考的你都會
就點擊下方PanSci泛科學商店的
第一個商品
現在有預購新書79折優惠
不得了下次世界大戰
痾
應該說世界小戰的關鍵武器誕生了
美國賓州大學與密西根大學的團隊
在 Science Robotics 上
發表了一款全球最小
且具備完整大腦的自主型機器人
這小傢伙尺寸只有200乘300乘50微米
比一粒鹽巴甚至比草履蟲還小
就算沒看過蟻人也知道
打造超微型機器人非常難
因為在我們的世界重力跟慣性是老大
但縮小到細胞等級的微觀世界
表面積產生的摩擦力和黏滯力才是大魔王
對這群機器人來說
在水裡游就像在濃稠的柏油裡掙扎
傳統的機械手腳難造就算了
就算造得出來也一動就斷
那該怎麼辦
科學家找上富士通(Fujitsu)的半導體廠
用55奈米的CMOS製程
把大腦整批印在晶圓上
團隊硬是在不到一公釐的空間
塞進太陽能板、記憶體
還有一顆功耗僅有75奈瓦的超省電處理器
只要曬到一點點LED燈光
就能持續運作好幾個月
但因為記憶體小到只能存幾百個位元
科學家被迫自創了一套
11位元的精簡指令集CISC
把原本要寫幾百行代碼的動作
壓縮成一行大招指令就能搞定
而且為了防止它被路邊亂閃的燈光干擾
還設有密碼鎖系統
機器人要辨識出
正確的閃光序列 (Passcode)
才會乖乖接收指令不然就忽視
要把這群小腦袋從晶圓上放生也很有戲
科學家先將晶圓背面磨薄到只有50微米
大概一根頭髮厚
再用電漿蝕刻像切餅乾一樣把它們切出來
最後用化學藥劑溶解支撐層
機器人就會批量掉進水裡
這個暴力的出生過程良率大約50%
雖然以TSMC標準不太OK
但 OK
下水後它沒有引擎
而是改用電動力推進
意思是機器人透過鉑金電極放出電場
去撩水裡的離子
讓這些離子像魚人空手道一樣
拖著周圍的水分子跑
自己給自己開了一條人工運河
它甚至能執行高難度的趨溫性任務
當感應器偵測到溫度降低
機器人會啟動弧線探險模式去尋找熱源
一旦發現變暖
就會切換成原地旋轉安穩待著
最萌的是溝通方式這機器人會跳扭扭舞
它測到溫度後會控制身體左右搖擺
這種搖擺舞其實是曼徹斯特編碼
科學家透過顯微鏡錄影並解碼
就能讀取數據
這溝通方式簡直跟蜜蜂一模一樣
とてもかわいい
しかし
這群造價台幣三毛錢的小東西
也可以是恐怖的間諜
撒在你家可以潛伏好幾個月
吸進去進入血管他們就會瞬間復活
好比三屍腦神丹
目前科學家替它們設定的志向
也的確是進入血管監控細胞健康
或是更進一步在身體裡
協同組裝超精密的微型零件
看來未來戰爭不是比誰的飛彈大
而是比誰的機器人小
小到防不勝防
蛤
要是吞進去怎麼辦
可能得定期找藉口去敵國開會吧
你覺得人生好難焦慮到想躲進棉被嗎
但剛剛發表在當代生物學期刊上的研究
給了我們一個對焦慮的全新認知
故事是這樣的
科學家通常用一種叫
高架十字迷宮(EPM)的刑具
來測試老鼠
這迷宮有兩條是有牆壁的巷子很安全
另外兩條是懸空的獨木橋很可怕
一般的實驗室老鼠只要上去過一次
被嚇到了
這輩子就絕對不會再走去懸空的那一邊
這叫單次試驗耐受性
基本上就是老鼠版的PTSD
而且這創傷頑固到
連醫生開的抗焦慮藥物都壓不下來
但美國康乃爾大學的團隊發現
只要把那些焦慮到不行的實驗室肥宅老鼠
丟去野外求生一個禮拜
牠們的焦慮症竟然就不藥而癒了
科學家將這群藥石罔效的老鼠
從狹窄的籠子裡抓出來
丟進一個450平方公尺大的戶外圍欄
這空間比牠們原本的家大了9000倍
有土有草有風吹有日曬
也就是把家裡蹲
強迫丟進瑪利亞之牆外的世界來個野蠻遊戲
一開始這些老鼠可能還在發抖
但過沒幾天牠們就
せーの
でもそんなんじゃだめ
もうそんなんじゃほら
心は進化するよもっともっと
沒錯牠們的心真的進化了
才過了一個禮拜
科學家把老鼠抓回來再測一次
這群老鼠竟然大搖大擺地走上懸空的獨木橋
探索時間直接翻倍
完全忘記了之前的恐懼
變得ふわふわり
科學家認為這不是因為牠們腦子壞了
而是因為牠們的威脅資料庫更新了
跟對照組老鼠一比
牠們雖然同樣得了PTSD
但繼續住在實驗室籠子裡
結果他們一週後一樣怕甚至更怕
這證明了恐懼不會自己消失
是被戶外經驗給洗掉了
但別誤會這不是在說焦慮的人都是溫室花朵
科學家指出焦慮
其實是大腦的一種數據校準機制
我們的大腦需要大量的風險數據
來判斷什麼是危險
但現代社會過度保護環境太單調
在這種環境下大腦缺乏參照物
自然會把一點點未知
比如獨木橋或跟陌生人社交
誤判成世界末日
所以如果覺得焦慮別認為是自己軟弱
其實是因為這個社會把我們關太久了
大腦為了保護我們
在資料不足的情況下開啟了最高警戒模式
當然人類的情況比老鼠複雜得多
該看醫生的還是要看醫生
但這研究告訴我們偶爾去Touch Grass
讓大腦見識一下大風大浪
或許能幫我們的警報系統進行一次校正回歸
如果還是不想出門
那玩艾爾登法環應該也行
起碼那裡的焦慮是確定的
You Died
只看臉錯了嗎
一項剛發表在PLOS ONE上的研究
讓只看臉的科學家
臉綠了
在距今180萬年前的
喬治亞共和國德馬尼西遺址
科學家挖到了五顆古人類頭骨
這五顆頭骨雖然埋在一起
但長得實在太不像了
有的臉超大有的臉超小
過去科學家一直用
哎呀 這就是男女差別嘛來解釋
認為大臉的是男生小臉的是女生
大家都是相親相愛的一家人
但巴西聖保羅大學的團隊覺得
這這這只看臉怎麼行
於是祭出最Hardcore的牙齒鑑識法
為什麼是牙齒
因為過了幾百萬年
骨頭埋在土裡會被壓扁變形
所謂的臉大臉小可能有誤差
就跟20年款跟
25年款的Joeman就是不一樣
但牙齒表面的琺瑯質是人體最硬的東西
它保留了最原始最真實的生物條碼
研究團隊進行了三步驟的嚴格考察
第一步建立數據庫
從700萬年前的早期人科到3萬年前的智人
團隊大手筆總共蒐集了122個古人類個體
共583顆牙齒的精密數據
重點是他們計算的是牙冠面積
也就是牙齒的長乘以寬
因為這是演化史上最穩定的特徵
就像是生物的QR Code
第二步AI判讀
他們利用線性判別分析(LDA)
這種統計演算法來進行分類
先把已知的物種數據餵給演算法訓練
建立好每個物種的特徵地圖
接著把德馬尼西
那幾顆身份不明的牙齒丟進去
看它們究竟會掉進哪一個物種的籃子裡
第三步大猩猩測試
這招專門用來打臉性別差異說
他們想男女差別是吧
好
那我們就來比比看誰的差別比較大
他們找來了靈長類中
性別二型性最誇張的大猩猩
牠們公母體型差非常多
研究團隊計算了公母猩猩牙齒大小的比例
以此作為單一物種差異的極限值
結果發現德馬尼西這幾具化石的牙齒差異
竟然跟大猩猩一樣誇張
除非早期人類的公母體型差跟金剛一樣大
否則這絕對不是同一家人的特徵
這代表這五個人很可能分屬兩個不同的物種
所以那個下巴超大
牙齒結構很原始的Skull 5
被歸類為更像南方古猿的新物種
Homo georgicus 喬治亞人
而其他長得比較像現代人的
則被歸類為Homo caucasi高加索人
這可不得了
難道180萬年前的那場走出非洲大遷徙
不是直立人的獨角戲
而是至少有兩個不同的人類物種
在同一時間同一地點一起生活
甚至是一起組隊去冒險的嗎
這畫面光想就很魔幻
兩個長相智力可能都不同的人種
竟然能跨越物種的隔閡
一起離開家鄉去探索世界
這實在太 DEI 了太像萊歐斯小隊了
希望他們最後不是把彼此吃了
誰說攻受不可逆
史上第一次科學逆轉了阿茲海默晚期重症
這項發表在 Cell Reports Medicine 上
的重磅研究
徹底扭轉我們這一百年來對失智症的絕望感
堪稱2026開年頭號好消息
這研究由美國凱斯西儲大學
結合了致力於將諾貝爾獎級研究
轉化為藥物的哈靈頓發現研究所
所組成的神經科學特種部隊
領頭的Andrew Pieper博士
正是這款神秘藥物P7C3的發明者
過去幾十年對抗阿茲海默症的思路
主要都是清垃圾
也就是想辦法清除腦袋裡的類澱粉蛋白斑塊
或是Tau蛋白糾結
但現實很殘酷
這些藥物往往只能稍微延緩惡化
很難真正救回瀕死的腦細胞
而這次的研究團隊非常叛逆
他們認為問題核心不在身為攻的垃圾本身
而在於身為受的大腦沒電了
他們找來了兩種已經病入膏肓的小鼠
第一種是5xFAD小鼠
滿腦子都是類澱粉蛋白斑塊
第二種是PS19小鼠
腦袋裡塞滿了Tau蛋白糾結
這時年紀都很大記憶力崩壞只能等死
團隊給牠們打了一種代號
P7C3-A20 的藥物
這藥物不直接去清垃圾
而是做了一件更基礎的事
修復大腦的NAD+系統
這個NAD+是所有活細胞都需要的關鍵輔酶
既是細胞產生能量的必需品
又是修復受損DNA的關鍵原料非常重要
而阿茲海默症患者的大腦
就像是停工又缺料的工廠
因為NAD+耗盡
神經細胞不僅沒有電力運轉
更沒有零件去修復毒性蛋白造成的破壞
最終只能報廢
而P7C3-A20的作用就是重新啟動供應鏈
讓大腦恢復製造NAD+的能力
一旦電力和零件都補足了
細胞就能重新開工開始自助大掃除和維修
連續治療幾個月後
科學家把這些老鼠丟進水迷宮游泳
放在滾輪上跑步
結果所有人都驚呆了
這些原本已經失智路都走不好的老鼠
記憶力和運動能力竟然完全恢復
不輸健康的年輕小鼠
高唱 One more time
wanna get lost in the ni-ni-night
切開大腦一看更不得了
原本破爛的血腦屏障修好了
發炎反應消失了
甚至連斷裂的DNA都自己接回去了
更重要的是團隊分析了人類患者的腦組織
發現人類阿茲海默症大腦裡
NAD+的合成酵素也有一樣的崩壞現象
這強烈暗示
如果我們能修復人類大腦的NAD+系統
或許失智症就不再是通往虛無的單程票
而是可逆向的旅程
當然我不是老鼠你也不是
應該不是
但這研究告訴我們
大腦的韌性比我們想像的還要強
多睡覺多運動保護好大腦代謝功能之外
只要給它足夠的修復原料
或許真的能自己的大腦自己救
蛤
支持腦細胞算不算挑釁類澱粉蛋白
剛發表在皇家天文學會月報上的最新研究
給了天文學界一記重擊
由希臘雅典國家天文台領軍的團隊發現
我們拿來測量宇宙大小的重要尺規
類星體Quasars
它的刻度竟然會隨著時間自己變形
要知道這有多尷尬
得先談談宇宙怎麼量
大家熟知的宇宙標準尺叫做Ia型超新星
它爆炸時的亮度非常一致
就像工廠的標準燈泡
只要看它在地球上看起來有多暗
就知道它離我們多遠
但有個致命缺點不夠亮
只能幫我們測量中年以後的宇宙
再遠就看不到了
所以天文學家把希望寄託在類星體身上
它們是宇宙中最亮的燈塔
可以比整個星系還亮1000倍
能讓我們看到宇宙邊緣
早在將近50年前天文學家就發現了
類星體的紫外線和X光亮度之間
有一個固定的比例關係
這條定律在2015年左右
被科學家進一步改良
正式成為測量深空宇宙的標準燭光候選人
但這個機制是怎麼來的
簡單說因為我也只能簡單說
黑洞周圍有一個由氣體組成的吸積盤
因為摩擦生熱會發出強烈的紫外線UV
而在黑洞更內圈
包覆著一團神祕的高能電子雲
這東西就像是高能變壓器
會攔截吸積盤發出的紫外線
把牠們加工升級成能量更高的X光
既然如此科學家就同時測量這顆類星體的
紫外線亮度和X光亮度
因為這兩者之間
存在那個50年前發現的特殊關係
只要代進公式
就能反推出這顆類星體真正的距離
但這把尺真的在宇宙的每個角落
每個時代都一樣準嗎
科學家心裡始終有個疙瘩
對科學家就是心裡很多疙瘩
於是他們結合了位在太空負責看X光的
德國eROSITA望遠鏡
和位在地面負責看可見光與紫外線的
SDSS巡天計畫
分析了136745個類星體
超越過往研究好幾個量級
他們還用演算法幫黑洞P圖去背
不是為了把外星人修掉
應該不是
而是因為類星體的星系裡
有其他恆星也會發光
為了不讓雜訊干擾
他們把背景星系的光通通修掉
同理有些黑洞會有強大的噴流也會發出X光
為了怕搞混
他們也把這些有噴流的黑洞全部排除
剔的一乾二淨之後結果這把尺破功了
數據顯示這條X光與紫外線的關係線
在100億年前的早期宇宙
跟現代黑洞竟然不同
古代的關係線比較平緩
暗示古代黑洞內部結構可能跟現代不一樣
能量傳輸更有效率
再來他們又發現
古代類星體的數據點分佈比較緊密
誤差範圍比較小
代表古代黑洞可能比較純樸
現代黑洞變得越來越浪蕩
有的亮有的暗結構變得更混亂
最後過去很多模型認為
黑洞吞噬的速度(愛丁頓比率)
應該會影響X光的產量
結果數據一跑完全沒關係
不管是暴飲暴食還是細嚼慢嚥
發光比例都差不多
打臉了一票現有的吸積盤理論模型
這下尷尬了
因為那些試圖用類星體去測量宇宙嬰兒時期
甚至宣稱發現暗能量異常的新理論
現在通通被打上了大問號
不過這就是科學總是準備被推翻
就跟你的新年新希望一樣
欸 你也是盯著插座 車頭 雲朵
覺得它們都有頭有臉嗎
這種現象叫做臉孔視錯覺(Face Pareidolia)
是人類大腦為了社交需求
演化出來的正常功能
畢竟寧可看錯不可錯過
但但但如果你發現自己
一直看錯老是看錯
甚至連火龍果切面裡都能看出人臉
那可能要注意了
發表在心理學期刊Perception上的
最新研究發現
這可能跟一種神祕的
視雪症(Visual Snow Syndrome)有關
欸 是視雪不是食雪
所謂的視雪症就像是電視機訊號沒接好
患者的視野裡永遠都覆蓋著一層
像電視雜訊一樣的閃爍光點
不管白天黑夜都關不掉
蛤你很年輕從來沒看過電視的雪花雜訊
Sheee
這項由澳洲昆士蘭大學
Jessica Taubert團隊領軍的研究
找來了132位視雪症患者
和104位普通人進行測試
為什麼要研究這個
因為視雪症就跟
I can see dead people 一樣
醫生只能聽患者説我看得到靜電雜訊
如果是小孩或無法言語的人只能默默忍受
許多患者甚至被誤診為偏頭痛 飛蚊症
甚至是心理作用或精神異常
所以澳洲昆士蘭大學的團隊
想找出一個客觀的證據
來辨別患者的大腦視覺系統
是不是真的跟一般人不一樣
團隊給受試者看了一堆普通的物體照片
比如吐司 青椒 咖啡拉花
然後問他們你在裡面看到臉了嗎
有多像
為了避免有人亂答
他們在測試圖片中
混入了32張真正的人臉照片
如果沒認出真臉或者隨便填
整組數據直接作廢
這剔除了超過一半(301人)的受試者
只留下最精確最認真的數據
結果科學家發現
視雪症患者是超強人臉偵測機
給出的分數顯著高於一般人
也就是說
他們更容易把隨機的圖案腦補成人臉
而且兩組人的判斷邏輯其實是一模一樣的
普通人覺得最像臉的那幾張圖
患者也覺得最像
普通人覺得最不像的患者也排在最後面
這很重要
證明了患者沒有瘋
也沒有產生奇怪的幻覺
但
他們把每一張圖的分數都加權了
普通人覺得一點點像的
在他們眼裡變成蠻像的
普通人覺得蠻像的
在他們眼裡變成超像的
他們接收到的訊號模式是對的
跟一般人排序一致
但卻把所有訊號的音量旋鈕都轉到最大
這證實了視雪症的神經機制假說
視覺皮質過度興奮 Hyperexcitability
意思是說我們大腦平常有一個踩煞車的機制
潛意識先猜那是人臉
理智再修正 不 那是插座
但視雪症患者因為大腦皮質過度亢奮
煞車失靈無法修正錯誤的猜測
反而認定那是真實的訊號
終於這研究給了視雪症一個生理證明
也提供了一個實用診斷工具
未來醫生或許只要拿幾張很難辨識的圖片
給小朋友看
測一下看錯臉的程度
就能協助判斷大腦是不是太High
而不必再依賴模糊的口述
而如果你朋友指著空無一人的角落說
他在看我
也許只是他大腦的ISO值調太高了
蛤你沒有朋友啊
你回頭看看那個角落就會看到了
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想吐槽
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了 按讚 訂閱 開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼比角落的好朋友
還可愛的背景圖歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄
我們下週見